i come from the left
i used to be woke
i'm not anymore
and i said oh my god
i have gone right from my childhood home
back out into the world and this is the
world we're living in now because the
same abusive exploitative tactics that i
know at home i'm seeing in my friend's
circles i'm seeing in the
you know the democratic voters
political circles that i'm talking about
and i'm not saying that only people on
the left
have a certain psychological disorder
that's not what i'm saying but i am
saying right now
in the western world on the left
it looks like it has a really bad case
of a cluster b personality disorder
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissinger
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
host of the disaffected podcast josh
lockham welcome to trigonometry
thanks guys thanks for having me oh it's
a great pleasure to have you on we've
been trying to make it happen for a long
time we're delighted we've finally been
able to uh to make it work for anyone
who doesn't know who you are tell
everybody who are you how are you where
you are what has been your journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
well as you said i host a weekly podcast
called disaffected while i say weekly we
do a television show on sundays and
audio during the week uh and it's a show
that looks at modern culture and
politics through a psychological lens
i am not a mental health professional
uh i'm not a credentialed professional i
don't represent myself as one but i'm
somebody who has personal experience
with domestic abuse family abuse um and
mental illness uh that it affected my
family's life and i've begun to believe
that the kinds of distorted dynamics um
lack of emotional control
narcissistic exploitation that are
common to abusive family backgrounds has
been spilling out and infecting our
public culture to such a degree that it
alarmed me enough that that that is the
focus of the show that i'm on
or that i host rather
well it's it's fascinating because i've
always said from the moment that we saw
some of these ideologies start to play
themselves out someone who's done a lot
of
personal development stuff and learned
psychology at university and all that
sort of thing it was kind of obvious to
me that
excuse me a lot of the stuff seems to be
people projecting their own personal
traumas onto the world like i had a bad
experience with my dad therefore all men
are evil or i had this therefore all
that is that the kind of thing that you
talk about
uh yeah what what we talk about what i
focus on are what are called
cluster b
personality disorders
and the
tactics and
uh abuse dynamics that attend to those
uh so yeah it involves a lot of things
like projection of your own trauma onto
the world
victim signaling in order to get uh
virtue points i mean we've we've all
talked about all of this stuff
and
it's it's interesting to me because i
think that
when you talk about projection for
example
projection is something that all humans
do
but it's something that has become
a sort of excessively popular uh in the
internet age and in the past five to ten
years
and
it's also something that interestingly
uh people have said
uh when they watch a show like the one i
do where i talk about my personal
background in my family with people with
personality disorders and i liken them
to i mean what you can call it woke if
you want you can call it the successor
ideology
whatever term it is that you're
comfortable with this cultural moment
that we're living in right now seems to
me to be characterized by an excess of
clinical levels of narcissism
dysfunctional levels of narcissism
projection of internal rage onto other
people
um
so so yes it is that sort of thing and
i think it might be helpful
um to tell people exactly what cluster b
personality disorders are and and why
why talk about them so
we're talking about mental illness most
people when you use the term mental
illness most people think of things like
severe depression
anxiety maybe obsessive compulsive
disorder maybe something like
schizophrenia where a person is actually
literally disconnected from reality
personality disorders if you want to
call them a mental illness are a
somewhat different kind of mental
illness
and i'm speaking in rough generalities
there is overlap here but in general
you can see a person who might suffer
from intermittent depression or
intermittent anxiety
and you can think of it as kind of a
dark cloud that comes in and may make a
couple of weeks or a month in that
person's life really tough it might make
them a hard company to be around
but it can be treated and it comes and
goes personality disorders are not like
that they're basically what they say on
the tin they are disorders of
personality or character if you will
they're ingrained long-term
dysfunctional ways of thinking about
yourself and thinking about and relating
to other people they don't go away
they're consistent across various parts
of your life they may not be exactly the
same in each situation
but we're talking about
fundamental character issues
that affect how a person relates to
other people and they're unfortunately
really
resistant to treatment
so what are the cluster b's
they are borderline personality disorder
narcissistic personality disorder
histrionic personality disorder and
anti-social personality disorder which
is a synonym for sociopathy or
psychopathy these are called the
dramatic and erratic personality
disorders
so the example that i would give people
want to understand how i conceive of
this and where i came from
i am estranged from my mother
um
my mother uh my best guess for my mother
is that she has borderline and
narcissistic personality disorders and
the quick way that i i give people an
insight into this although i i'm in an
age now where
i i'm in middle age and i know a lot of
people aren't going to get my references
so if you don't get these movies you'll
you know i'll have to find it would be
fine we're middle aged as well and our
audience is even older don't worry about
that
i'm still young [ __ ] both of you
i know
i'm 75 years younger
if you want to know what kind of
childhood i had if you want to know what
kind of person my mother was
this sounds a little flip and it is a
little funny and it's okay to laugh at
it but i mean it actually literally my
mother was a cross between a trailer
park version of joan crawford and mommy
dearest and the mother in the horror
movie carrie that is the kind of
personality style that my mother has
that was
what our childhood was like
growing up absolute emotional
instability
um
a parent who turned her children into
her caregivers doing work around the
house being an emotional confidant for
her children um telling them secrets
romantic secrets even that they never
should have uh should have learned
um a series of relationships with men
who were physically violent and abusive
to her children these are you know my
story is not unique there are a lot of
people sadly who come from backgrounds
like this but there is a commonality
this isn't just well some people fall
into
these terrible situations what's going
on here
is
serious and severe personality disorders
emotional dysregulation
exploitative behavior even towards your
own children
this kind of stuff
well the way i say it is
domestic abuse has gone public it's gone
feral the sorts of things that i saw in
my home growing up that i did not
understand are now happening in the
wider world and i see them
i see them excessively
on what i have been calling the woke
left but unfortunately it has infected
at least in the united states the
mainstream left the location josh hold
on a second there i'm loving what you're
saying i'm completely on board can you
give me some concrete examples of that
please
yes so
um
virtue signaling we hear that term a lot
everybody today is a victim if you want
to get attention if you want to get a
story written about you if you want if
you want your true your tweet to go
viral you have to claim victimhood
somebody said something to you
that was racist somebody said something
that was transphobic somebody did not
respect your pronouns the level of
offense
um that is given to these things is so
excessive and it seems like culturally
we've been trained to just respond to
that oh you know that's very very sad
but what do we see
perfect example from u.s media this week
new york times reporter taylor lorenz um
who is somebody who's written a lot of
work for the new york times
that people i think rightly have said
you're trying to get people canceled
you're trying to ruin their reputations
they're not living up to woke standards
and yet a journalist like this will be
interviewed by msnbc and say that the
criticism that she got for this gave her
post-traumatic stress disorder so it's a
reversal
reversals of victim and offender
and we see this a lot i think you guys
see that a lot you've told you've had
guests on your show who've talked about
that dynamic
no yes we have indeed
the thing that worries me josh is the
fact that people can monetize this
behavior and once you can monetize it
it's the ultimate incentive
yeah well you can monetize it right you
can build a personal brand out of being
a victim and lots of people have done it
i mean
you know i think there was an abortive
attempt with the oscars jada pinkett
smith i think wanted to be the world's
biggest victim for having a
disability called alopecia
be careful now i'm losing my hair as
well josh
i'm gonna have to fly over there and
slap you
isn't that just how it is though men
just lose their hair and go bald but
when famous women lose their hair and go
bald they don't just go bald they have a
disability called alopecia it's an
illness
that that that's part of it i think we
see these double standards here too
um
yes francis you can monetize it but i
think
i think being a victim pays in currency
other than cash too i think it pays in
what you can call narcissistic supply
and that's the term that people use um
adapted from talk about drug culture
right you're getting that feeling of
praise you're getting that high
from the attention and it gives you
status it gives you social status
particularly on the left the more of a
victim you are the higher you are in in
sort of the symbolic hierarchy
uh so i think it's monetizable but i
think it's also
monetizable if you will
uh in a social way and and honestly i
think for a lot of people
that social attention may be even more
attractive than the money
and it's particularly when you think
about narcissism now we were now we're
stand-up comedians and we were involved
in an industry stuffed to the brim with
narcissus and what was really
fascinating josh is the moment this
you know this culture this way of
thinking this ideology seeped in you
started to see more and more people
describe themselves as gender non-binary
pronouns in bio
all of these different things
fat activists
now i never that like when i grew up
there was no such thing but people were
legitimately calling themselves fat
activist
anti-racist
it just seems as like
this kind of toxic relationship between
the ideology
and the narcissism and let's be fair
we've all got narcissism laden within us
so it's also kind of it's corrosive as
well because it's encouraging us to
behave this way
absolutely narcissism is socially
rewarded now there's always been it's
always been the case take take an
industry like hollywood hollywood is
full of broken people this is where
children from broken homes uh
traumatizing homes inadequate neglectful
backgrounds this is where they go
i'm not saying they do it consciously
but this happens to a lot of creative
people you know they're trying to find a
way through art through self-expression
maybe to make themselves whole again or
or to get some satisfaction out of that
work that feels more meaningful but
unfortunately
when you're in a place like hollywood
the more outrageously you behave the
more diva like you behave the more
attention you get and and i i don't
think hollywood is a place that you go
to in order to get
uh mentally better
you know
um
there was a line there was a really
great series on fx a few years ago that
looked at um the last years of the
famous actresses joan crawford and betty
davis's life and there was a scene
in there where joan crawford was in the
hospital you know huge narcissist
and the publicist says to her you know
the thing about hollywood
i don't know if it creates narcissists
or attracts people like you
and and that's the question i i think
it's i think it's both
uh but it's definitely incentivized
but but and it's a great point but the
problem is instead of having as in john
crawford's times in the 50s and the 60s
you had an industry which created
narcissists we now have these platforms
which is turning the whole society our
whole society into into one big
narcissist
yeah well yeah one big narcissist or one
big borderline uh as i would say it i
you know i was looking at something this
morning i thought you guys would be
interested in um because people ask this
a lot well how many people actually have
a full-on personality disorder right and
you said francis and you're right we all
have some narcissism in us here's the
thing about these traits that we talk
about even if we talk about them in
personality disorders or in
non-personality disorder people almost
all of these traits are human traits
they're not
personality disorder people traits
we all have a degree of narcissism some
of it we need some of it is healthy
we're talking about excess here we all
have a degree of self-regard or ability
or inability to to regulate our emotions
this is normal but the people
that we could look at and say you have a
real pathological level problem
have these
so consistently and so extremely
even though many people don't recognize
it immediately there are different kinds
of being narcissistic
there are kinds that are
very easy to see and there there are
types that are more covert
but how many people have them if you
look at the literature you go to the
psych literature and you look at the
average estimates that come from the
professional organizations you'll get
something between
one to three percent they believe in the
general population have a cluster b
personality disorder i don't believe
this for a moment
i suspect all along even before our
modern era that was probably an
underestimate
um my guess and it's just a guess it's
from experience i'm a decently well-read
layman but again not a credentialed
professional
i would guess that around 10 of our
population right now would fit the full
diagnostic criteria for a full disorder
and that there are many more of us who
have an extra helping of these traits or
these traits are being encouraged
one thing i looked at and i talked about
this on the show earlier
uh this year
back in 2013 there was a really
interesting article from a couple of
clinicians and college professors who
were noticing an explosion
of narcissism
and emotional instability and public
temper tantrums among their students and
they said
why does it look to us like every other
person who's coming by has borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder so they decided to
do a survey and they looked at 351
students in the survey and they expected
to find the one to three percent
of them would meet these criteria here's
what they actually found
for histrionic that you know excessive
over the top melodramatic historic
personality disorder thirty percent of
this student surveyed met the criteria
for narcissistic personality disorder 21
of the students they surveyed fit that
category
that is
completely terrifying well let me ask
you something josh because how much of
this is
we now have a method for all those
people to express themselves as francis
says in the past if you were someone
like this you'd go into hollywood or
into stand-up or whatever and now you
don't need to do that you've got a phone
and you can just do it or there's a
other side of it which is
how much is social media incentivizing
rewarding and therefore generating uh
this sort of uh behavior in all of us
when it's really not very healthy for
any person to be using it
oh big time i couldn't quantify it but
it
clearly social media is one of the
one of the primary ingredients that has
made this possible i don't think it
would be possible to this degree if we
did not have easy access to
brand me on facebook or twitter or
instagram
and
the artificial way that social media has
us communicate it strips context
um because of the medium itself it
strips out tone of voice often if you're
just typing
you're not sitting in a room where
you're reading people back and forth and
getting their body language in person
it is set up in such a way that it
thrives on big emotions big emotions in
me big emotions in you we're all trying
to provoke emotional reactions
and even the nicest people even the most
sort of butter wouldn't melt in your
mouth people who never lose their temper
bad behavior is encouraged and almost
pushed by these media and it can make
good people act like bad people it can
it can make people who are having a bad
day have several bad days in a row but
it definitely it's kind of like
lifeblood for the people who are the
hardcore committed narcissistic people i
mean there's no better way for them to
get supplies so yeah i think that has a
huge
huge amount to do with it
hey constantine do you want better
mental health i'm from russia we don't
have mental health so how do you deal
with mental health you drink vodka then
go out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real
man what about the bears feelings it's
russian bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my adhd
and become better in all areas of my
life why is he telling them how weak he
is drink vodka feel better
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to trigonometry funds get
10 percent of their first month at
betterhelp.com forward slash trigger
especially if they're not real men
that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com slash
trigger
and what effect is this having on
society with the way we interact with
each other what's it doing to the
cohesiveness of our relationships
it's destroying them it's absolutely
destroying them
that's the reason why i talk about this
on the show i'm terrified of where our
society is going
i believe we are living in a cluster b
world we are living in a world right now
in the west that is running along
cluster b slash
abusive household rules and
i want to say for people
a lot of people say i've never heard of
this kind of thing before
you may not have heard the term but you
know these people and you do know this
type of character you may know it by
different names if you have ever known
a couple
that had a domestic abuse situation wife
battering or mutual spouse battering
if you know people who had abuse of
childhoods
generally speaking the psychology of the
domestic abuser whether it's physical
emotional verbal or all of them in terms
of the abuse that's cluster b psychology
this is personality disorder stuff going
on
another term for it is cults cult rules
are cluster b rules
authoritarianism
um monitoring other people's emotions
and decisions and choices to make sure
that they line up with yours
this isn't new
and in fact these peop these kinds of
people in these kinds of psychological
states i think uh have been written
about for thousands of years the
ancients knew who they were i think they
are reflected in our mythology the
vampires the unquiet dead the succubus a
lot of these things can be read as
allegories for these kinds of
exploitative people you will often see
narcissistic people particularly
the seductive
maybe sexually maybe not sexually but
very seductive and charismatic
narcissistic people are often described
as emotional vampires and it's a really
great metaphor because that's what it
feels like feels like your
emotional energy is being sucked out of
you and brought into someone else
[Music]
i'm only
six years five or six years into
realizing
this
uh if i'm right about it
what you your first question that you
always ask and that you asked me
what brought you to be sitting in this
seat today
um
five or six years ago
i i'm not a religious person but in
terms of of the effect that it had i
would describe what happened to me five
or six years ago as an awakening
after many many years of not living
around or near my family i made a very
bad decision i made a foolish decision i
thought that i could love my mother back
to health and i decided to bring her
back into my life
put her in a house that i owned that she
could afford because she was poor and i
thought you know i'll be retirement for
my parents
and within two years of doing that all
the the screaming
the pathological lying the exploitation
um
theft i
you name it all of that stuff began
happening at a rapid pace and i sat
there and i looked at myself and i said
what is going on here i feel like i've
gone right back to my childhood
and it became so overwhelming
that
i had a nervous breakdown
and i don't say that to be dramatic and
i don't want anybody to say oh my god
i'm so sorry pity pity worst thing that
ever happened but the best thing i ever
had that ever happened to me because my
mother's pathological behavior was so
extreme and so right in my face and i
was in my 40s and i said something is so
severely wrong here and if i don't put a
stop to it right now
it's it's gonna have an effect on my
health
and
i i did have to put a stop to it um i
did have to go through a legal battle uh
to separate myself from my mother and
our rental situation
and
it woke me up i finally had an answer
and this is what i would say to people
watching or listening
when i learned what personality
disorders were i finally had a way to
understand
what in my head was
my mother's crazy but i can't explain it
and i can't explain it to other people
they won't understand i don't have
friends come over to my house because
i'm embarrassed of what they'll see if
they see my mother behind closed doors
all of a sudden it wasn't just this
crazy way my mother was
this was a known syndrome
and
the worst part though
was after coming to that realization and
saying i don't want this in my life
anymore i looked around me because i
come from the left
i used to be woke
i'm not anymore
and i said oh my god
i have gone right from my childhood home
back out into the world and this is the
world we're living in now because the
same abusive exploitative tactics that i
know at home i'm seeing in my friends
circles i'm seeing in the
you know the democratic voters
political circles that i'm talking about
and i'm not saying that only people on
the left
have a certain psychological disorder
that's not what i'm saying but i am
saying right now
in the western world on the left
it looks like it has a really bad case
of a cluster b personality disorder
so
and and josh can i ask you something
because i've been thinking about this a
lot and maybe this isn't a particularly
interesting avenue but it just it makes
me curious you mentioned you being
awoken on the left and i know that one
of the things that i've identified as
someone who's got left-wing views and
right-wing views there is a tendency for
people on the left to feel like
uh
they have to be on that side of politics
because they experience themselves as
being somewhat vulnerable uh and so they
want a quote unquote fair society
because they know that in the fair
society maybe their their opportunities
and status will be elevated above what
it might have been in a more
meritocratic society where which is
where where the right might lean to and
by the way this isn't a pro right or
anti-left thing i'm just it's one of the
things i've observed we're also you know
particularly with the ukraine situation
now starting to see quite a lot of
pathologies on the right but in terms of
that talk to us about what was it that
you drew you to being woke i'm just
curious
um
this won't be the same for everybody
but this is how it was for me
i think
i think leftist politics
naturally pre-selects for people who
conceive of themselves as victims or as
people on whom
forces act right people who are victims
of systems
our family was poor
grew up
for a long time single mother household
my mother um i never even met my father
um my brother and sister come from a
different marriage
there was
physical battering and violence in the
home
um poverty
and
a
from a from the time it was a very young
child and again this is this is i mean
i'm telling you my story but this is the
story of millions of people there's
nothing unique about my family in terms
of the screwed up families
um i was
i was made in basically i was made into
my mother's surrogate husband
emotionally
um a caretaker for the younger children
um
a girlfriend sort of if you will to talk
to about all the terrible things men had
done to her i mean when i was a kid i
used to comfort my mother when she was
afraid of getting slapped around by my
stepfather while i was afraid as well
this kind of role reversal you see
reversal in all of this
and i'm gay
and
i was unable to face when i was a
teenager the reality of the psychiatric
derangement in my mother it was too much
for me to face
i interpreted my emotional instability
as a teenager and i had a lot of it and
um
my depression i had a couple of suicide
attempts at around 12 years old
i interpreted all of this as i'm gay and
everybody hates gay people and i'm
getting beat up at school so this is why
i'm depressed and that was part of it
but
really it was because i came from an
absolutely deranged household
and
i learned to see myself as a victim as a
minority i'm a gay man gay people are
oppressed i come from a low
socioeconomic background america hates
struggling single mothers and they
they're they're they're not generous
enough with welfare food stamp benefits
and i just took on these leftist
politics that my mother had
and i made them my own now i'm not
saying there's no way to be a liberal
that that isn't more considered than how
i got there there are ways to do that
but i see a whole bunch of this one of
the common characteristics i see
in people today
who hew very left is
they either
see themselves as having been victims of
structural racism structural misogyny
structural anti-poverty
and or they see the people that they
associate with as victims it's always an
outside force it's never that you didn't
make good choices
that's what's interesting it's it's
really interesting because as i
mentioned i think uh
on the right there is something
similar but different happening where
uh
i mean i think with the three of us who
all agree that we've all been lied to
for some time by mainstream media and
the establishment has been pushing
particular narratives but it's getting
to a point now where it feels like a lot
of people feel like
uh it's becoming an identity almost like
we've been lied to and now we've
discovered this thing that answers all
our questions have you noticed that or
is am i imagining that
are you saying uh
are you
i'm trying to figure out
are you saying that there's just as much
of a danger on the right of
adopting a new identity that says well
they all lie to us so they're always
wrong now is do it did i finish we're
victims we are victims we are victims of
this great conspiracy whatever that is
there's this sort of very simplistic
explanation to explain things that have
been happening just like structural
racism or homophobia that you know there
is an element of truth gay people have
been badly treated in the past black
people have been badly treated but the
explanation is overly simplistic and
emotionally disregulated it's like yes
you were not told the truth about brexit
and trump and and covert to some extent
and blah blah blah that does not mean
that when when mainstream media says
it's going to rain today it's definitely
going to be sunny and and there's not
going to be a single cli
i'm saying
i do yeah and and i think that is a
danger and it is something that people
are falling into there are conspiracies
you know what it bothers me
i
i hate the tone of like you see you even
see the word conspiracy theory printed
and you hear it in this voice
conspiracy theory right
drives me nuts because conspiracies are
real and positing that a conspiracy
happened is not a sign of oh he's kooky
right but
i don't a lot of things that
many people think our conspiracies i
don't think are conspiracy i think they
are
predictable
ways that patterns
interact with each other and have
certain outcomes so
you know there are people on the right
might say
um
well it's all conspiracy to do x y and z
or this is all a conspiracy to do
exactly um
to maneuver our children into this i
don't know that there are as many
conscious
mechanical conspiracies as there are
attractive ideas that serve certain
interests and that preferentially
attract the kind of people who
consciously or unconsciously will
exploit those dynamics for their own
social or monetary profit so i think a
lot of things tend to go together but it
doesn't necessarily mean that there's a
puppet master pulling particular strings
well that's exactly what i mean josh
because that's that's kind of the point
it is that while of course bad things
happen in the world and sometimes bad
things are done by other people so quite
often they're done because of you know
how
how appealing an idea is and the idea
might be very wrong or or they might
happen through the development of
certain social trends that aren't but
the point that i was getting at is i
think just like the structural
explanation is a very overly simplistic
way of talking about things or
misrepresenting things so this idea that
there's one group of people a small
group of people who are sort of in
charge of things it's quite an old theme
as well it's been around for a very long
time uh in the past too
yes you're this isn't this is a good
illustration of black and white thinking
either or thinking
this is a problem for all of us right
now and it's really tempting especially
when we're scared
and i'm scared
i am scared of where our society is
going it's really tempting to fall into
yes or no answers in black and white
thinking
rather
i think we need to go for discernment
and judgment
and do you notice
do you notice that one of the tenets of
being
a nice decent person on the left is
don't judge
don't be so judgmental
you do you
i'm not saying it's a conspiracy but
this is actu this is conscious and it is
serving a purpose
we have been told that to be nice people
to be decent and ethical people requires
us to suspend our judgment the word
judge has taken on a negative
connotation the same way the word
discrimination has it's almost
impossible to use the word discriminate
in its original meaning because people
believe discriminate equals bad
same thing with judge
that sounds judgmental sometimes
judgmentalism is required
but discernment is always required is it
really all the way yes is it really all
the way no or is it something else
um
yeah black and white thinking by the way
is very typical of the borderline
personality thinking style
and a way to think of that is
when people ask what's what's the easy
way to understand borderline personality
disorder think of the dynamic i hate you
don't leave me you know you're terrible
you're not giving me what i want you're
not living up to my expectations then
the next day oh my god oh my god you're
the best in the world don't ever leave
me i can't live without you oh i didn't
mean it etcetera etcetera this
you know overvaluing
people or ideas and then drastically
undervaluing them and vacillating
between these extremes is typical of
borderline personality thinking but it's
also more and more typical of the way
we're approaching our political
conversations and it is dangerous
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so we'll you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com
forward slash triggered that's
easydns.com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get
fifty percent off the initial purchase
sign up for their newsletter access of
easy which tells you everything you need
to know about technology privacy and
censorship the worrying thing josh for
us is we we've touched on cults is how
deeply attractive cults are from the
outside particularly in a world that we
live in that is becoming more and more
atomized families are breaking up
they're smaller we have that deep need
to belong to be part of a tribe
and so doesn't that make us more
susceptible to cults
sure i mean what it what is a cult other
than
you know
we like to i mean given my age when when
i think of cults i think of things like
the moonies and the hare krishnas right
which probably
nobody you know uh
younger millennials and younger were
probably like i have no idea what that
is but
we have this idea we've defined cults as
a small religious type group that has
one really weird and zany charismatic
leader i think we need to update our
definition of cults i don't think we
need a charismatic leader anymore i
think the leadership is distributed in
the social media age
i think all the elements of cult
thinking which are also cluster b slash
authoritarian slash abusive parent
thinking
all of those things are are present
we don't need to have one single
charismatic leader but yes when people
are scared they want to cleave to a
tribe
it happens to me
i used to be a liberal a leftist i'm not
anymore but i won't say i'm a
conservative
because there are emotional
things that attach to these words
and expectations that come along with
them
and i know it's clunkier but i wish
people would say to each other okay i'm
not going to ask you if you're a liberal
or conservative i'm going to ask you
what you think about this particular
issue and this particular issue in this
particular issue because i have i have
views that some people would consider
too left-leaning for their tastes uh and
i have a lot of views these days that
are far too right-leaning um for
for the people that i used to hang
around with um and like like many people
um
when i changed my mind politically over
the past five years i lost nearly all of
my friends
nearly all of my leftist friends and and
i i don't think we talk about this
enough
because i went through the same thing i
lost a lot of friends i know you did
and you still got me yeah
he said that in the most sinister manner
possible
but i don't think we talk enough about
how deeply distressing that is because
when you're part of a group or a cult or
a way of being and you suddenly leave it
it's like a death in a way i know that
sounds very dramatic but it is it's a
death of the of an old way of living
absolutely it abs it's a social death i
don't remember who said it recently but
it's it's a brilliant formulation
somebody like in somebody called cancel
culture social murder
and that's what it is reputation
destruction and being cast out this is
shunning this isn't new nothing we're
doing right now is
you know ooh it's 2022 we just figured
this no no this is ancient human
behavior this is the salem witch trials
this is the inquisition it goes back
even further than that
when people are shunned and ejected from
a community their moral status is taken
away from them their sense of identity
in some way is taken away from them it's
our responsibility to rebuild these
things ourselves i'm not suggesting it
you know uh you know i'm a victim now i
lost all my friend well i certainly felt
victimized in the moment that's a
natural emotion um
but
it's it's it's demoralizing it's it can
make people depressed it can make them
suicidally depressed
um it's vicious yeah it hurts
it does uh and the other thing about the
josh is we talk about my emotional
dysregulation or i call it emotional
incontinence where people just don't
know how to control their emotions our
mutual friend helen dale likes that
phrase too yeah yeah yeah i think it was
one that's going around and i just find
it that
our reaction as a society to a lot of
things that i consider fairly trivial or
minor
is now
oh oh you've got a different opinion uh
you think the tax system should work
differently you don't believe that this
thing that you are now all you know you
didn't post a black square on instagram
then you have to be socially murdered as
you put it right and again i don't
consider this a victimhood thing for me
because i know it's unpleasant to lose
friends and you know i've obviously gone
through as well but on the other hand i
went in into with my eyes open i knew
that this is the society we live in
and that's the cost of doing what you
believe to be doing i'm okay with that
but it just as as a as an observer of it
it seems very very
disproportionate to the so-called crime
and
where does that come from
cluster b
[Laughter]
maybe he's born with it maybe it's close
to b
um
well it
where does that come from it does come
that is a very typical
you can think of it as emotional
inflation right taking taking something
moderately or or minorly distressing and
and inflating it this is very very
typical of the histrionic personality
style the borderline personality style
but it's become normalized we have
normalized
we have normalized personality disorder
style relations we actively applaud and
affirm them
okay this whole sort of you know
well i'm going to say my piece no matter
what anybody has to say because i'm a
woman of color or i'm a trans person of
disability or i'm this or i'm that and
the more melodramatic and the more you
declare and the
the more strident your tone of voice the
more you get you go girl you go
you know it's i mean i i talked about
this on an episode of my show earlier
this week
a headline in one of the new york
newspapers talking about jada pinkett
smith's struggles with alopecia and
alopecia awareness advocates
are you kidding me
are you kidding struggle
an alopecia awareness
everything that is
frankly not very interesting or doesn't
need uh to be put on a pedestal is
elevated to this fever pitch of emotion
um
it's not real
it's not
well it's definitely not helping so josh
uh obviously we're focusing on negative
things here uh which is not unusual for
us because we're sort of looking at the
culture and trying to
say maybe we're going in the wrong
direction on some things but what what
can be done about this uh i know for
myself for example i do my very best not
to ever act like a victim not because
there aren't situations in which people
mistreat me or whatever but i just don't
think it's helpful to me and to my
well-being to consider myself that way
but me doing that doesn't seem to be
changing the culture sadly it's not
having that kind of impact so what do we
do as individuals and as a society to
try and overcome this because look let's
be honest right josh social media isn't
going away it's not it's not going to
disappear
it's not so
all this talk about social media is so
bad for us i agree but
the talking about it
it's not going to do [ __ ] right so we're
going to have to do something what can
we do
what we're doing right now what the
three of us are doing right now um and
and i'm glad you asked this because i
wanted to say it but i i didn't want to
say it in the beginning because i didn't
want to sound like i was buttering you
up so that you'd be nice to me during
the interview
but i mean this quite seriously your
show has been
a very important component in my
political maturation over the past
couple of years
when i was a lefty
um
i would not listen to conservative
viewpoints i had a very stereotyped view
of anybody who had political views that
were to the right of mine i engaged in a
lot of black and white thinking myself
i have some of these traits that i talk
about there are few children who come
from homes like i do who will not have
some of these emotional dysregulation
problems i think they're better today
um but i i understand them and i'm not
wholly outside that world myself
i
just basically assumed that people who
were on the right were morally deficient
i mean it's absurd and it's embarrassing
to say it but that is how i acted in the
world and
when i heard
i don't remember the first episode i
heard of your show
um it might even have been carrie smith
of unsafe space or it might have been
before then
but
you have such a variety of people on
your you have medical experts you have
researchers you have historians you have
people across
the political spectrum and the
commonality with all of them is that
they're unafraid of stating what they
believe to be true uh and expounding on
it in an interesting way i have listened
to more people with more political
points of view that i scoffed at before
because of your show than probably any
other single
uh source of media consumption so i'm
very grateful that you guys are out
there i mean it's interesting too but
it's actually been educational for me so
i think that we need to do
you need to do what you're doing i hope
that what i'm doing with disaffected
will be helpful to people
i wanted to be helpful in two ways
i want people to
make the connection to understand that
there is a way of understanding and
predicting the behavior in this world
culture if you understand these dynamics
i also hope that it will make people
feel that they are not crazy i have had
countless emails and
and messages from people saying
it sounds like you're narrating my
childhood life or it sounds like you're
narrating my marriage or what happened
to me in my woke group when i was
ejected but i didn't know there was a
name for it and i didn't know there was
a way to understand it and i'm not i'm
not trying to pick myself up because i
didn't understand this until six years
ago either
i think we have to keep doing these
things
i confess that i don't have a better
answer for you other than
talk about it and have conversations
with people who want to change it i
don't know how to fix it
and i suspect
i'm
i'm
well i think i'm realistic but a lot of
people call me cynical
um
from personal experience and from
observation in the world i think it's
usually true
that a problem has to get so acute and
so unbearably painful
that we have no choice but to stand up
and confront it and walk down a
different road
um
regardless of your efforts my efforts
the efforts of other people in this kind
of conversation
[ __ ] may have to fall apart a little bit
more
time will tell
and josh on a micro level
what do you say to those people who are
watching or listening to this and
thinking holy [ __ ] my partner friend
blah blah blah is a cluster b
personality what do they do
um
talk to
talk to other people who are in your
situation talk to other people who have
abusive family structures
um
read read
consume
educate yourself about that
see i hate educate yourself
we can't even say normal things anymore
um
when
my sister made a phone call to me that
changed my life six years ago when the
crisis with my mother was coming up i
had every excuse in the world i thought
maybe she has alzheimer's maybe she's
taken a fall maybe she has dementia why
is she acting this way
well i was trying to avoid the fact that
she'd acted this way my entire life and
i didn't want to admit it
my sister called me up
and said josh i think
i understand what's going on here i
think you need to read about this i
think our mother is a narcissist and i
think she has a cluster b personality
disorder so i went and i read the mayo
clinic the cleveland clinic
um
survivors forums i just read and read
and read and the more i read both the
clinical literature and the lay survivor
literature it was instantly clear to me
as as
much of a set piece as this sounds like
it's true
within three days
an entire lifetime
of baffling emotional dysregulation
abuse and lying slotted itself into
understandable categories it was like
watching a mechanical machine sorting
parts
all of a sudden i had clarity
that can happen for you too
um read about this learn about it talk
to other people watch my show send us an
email
um
the knowledge of this
just the knowledge alone that you are
not crazy to have noticed this and you
are not
you are not the terrible person
who has it coming the way the person
abusing you says or implies is worth so
much
that's a great note to to leave it josh
so we're going to ask you a couple of
questions from our supporters for our
supporters on locals only uh but before
we do that we always have one final
question as you know which is what is
the one thing we're not talking about
that we really should be i can see
you've got one ready to go you're you're
you're pumped and good
well i mean i am or you know i do
actually listen to your show every week
so i gave this some i gave this some
serious thought
and i think what i'd have to say is
what we're not talking about enough is
how rotten and disgusting sweet potatoes
are
yeah
um
maybe this isn't a problem in britain
but i'll tell you boys over here in the
united states people are trying to sneak
sweet potatoes into your stuff all the
time and i've had enough of it um so
you know people who watch my show know
that i'm sort of on a one-man campaign
to get rid of the fibrous nasty devils
tuber that is sweet potatoes but i would
like to raise awareness of the problem
with sweet potatoes fantastic well uh
controversial to the bitter end it's
been josh locum thank you so much for
coming on of the disaffected podcast
we're going to do a couple of questions
for our local supporters but thank you
for being here josh where can people
follow you online tell everybody where
to go
uh yep we are on youtube uh with our
channel disaffected we're on all the
major audio and video streaming
platforms disaffected podcast you want
show announcements on twitter at
disaffected p disaffected the letter p
thank you guys
fantastic it's been a pleasure thank you
guys for watching and listening we'll
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out at 7 p.m uk time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
a lot of the professional mental health
on offer is literally
validating actual delusion
and
disordered behavior and thinking and
calling it beautiful and authentic
[Music]
you